[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الى حصاد الليله معكم
حسن
وفي الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه
وتتفاعل اخرى
البدايه من واشنطن وتحديدا هذه الصوره
لمبنى الكونجرسون من الخارج بعد الاعلان
عن احتفاظ الديمقراطيين بالاغلبيه في مجلس
الشيوخ اثر ظهور نتائج ولايه نيفادا
والى رام الله حاله ترقب بعد تكليفنا ياهو
رسميا بتشكيل حكومه اسرائيليه واستقلق في
الداخل والخارج من صعود اليمين المتطرف
وفي مواضيع الحصاد لهذه الليله
في اول هجوم من نوعه يستهدف اسطنبول منذ
خمس سنوات
تفجير يهز شارع الاستقلال ويوقعوا قتلى
وجرحى السلطات تعتبر الهجوم ارهابيا وتقول
ان امراه هي من نفذت
فوق الصور
التنظيمات لم تنجح في تركيا الدوله
لكوريا الشماليه والبيت الابيض يستبق لقاء
بيض وشيجن بينج بتاكيد الرغبه في تنافس مع
الصين وليس في النزاع
لافروف يتم واشنطن وحلفائها بتقليد مصالح
موسكو وبيجين في المحيط الهادئ والرئيس
الاندلسي يحذر من تحويل المنطقه الى ساحه
صراعات دوليه
وسط قتال يحتدموا على الجبهات الشرقيه
ومحاولات تقدم الروسيه باتجاه المحوري
مدينه بخموت الاستراتيجيه مستشار الامن
القومي الامريكي
للانفتاح على المفاوضات واعاده النظر في
هدف استعاده القرن وكبير المفوضين
الاوكرانيين يتمسكوا بشرط استعاده كل
الاراضي قبل اي حوار مع موسكو
[موسيقى]
بعد الفوز في نيفادا الديمقراطيون يحافظون
على غالبيتهم في مجلس الشيوخ الامريكيه
مبددين امل الجمهوريين في موجه حمراء بيض
يقول ان النتائج تعبر عن اراده الامريكيين
بسبب سياسه الاجتماعيه للديمقراطيه ونانسي
تقول ان النتائج الجمهوريين في الانتخابات
اقل من المتوقع رغم التقارب في سباق بشان
مجلس النواب
في لقائنا اليوميه قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه
نقشنا المشهد الانتخابيه الامريكيه بعد
تاكد احتفاظ الديمقراطيين بالاغلبيه في
مجلس الشيوخ بينما تشير التقديرات الى فوز
الجمهوريين حتى الان
ب21 من اصل 118 مقعدا مطلوبا لتشكيل
الاغلبيه ارقام دفعت رئيسه مجلس النواب
الامريكي نانسي بيلوسي للقول باسمه من كان
يظن قبل شهرين ان هذه الموجه الحمراء
ستتحول الى قطره صغيره
كنا قد طرحنا عليكم السؤال الثالث برايكم
ما هي اسباب وحصاد الجمهوريين الانتخابيه
في الكونجرس الامريكي وقد جاءت النتائج
على الشكل التالي نحو 14% قالوا انه اقبال
قياسي للديمقراطيين على التصويت في حين
قال
28% انه فشل في تحديد شواغل الناخبين
الاكثر اهميه بينما قال
58% انه تحول المنافسه لاستفتاء على
دونالد ترامب هذا سؤال سيبقى مطروحا على
منصاتنا الرقميه يمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت
عبر مسح رمز
الظاهر على الشاشه
الرئيسيه يتجدد يوميا ولا نتطرق خلاله
لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله عربيا
وتتابعون في الحصاد ايضا
البرهان يحذر سياسيين من التدخل في شؤون
الجيش السوداني
الجيش
هي عدو بالنسبه لنا ولا حاجه
قتل سته اشخاص واصيب اكثر من ثمانين بجروح
في تفجير هذا شارع الاستقلاله في اسطنبول
وقال نائب الرئيس التركي ان التفجير عمل
ارهابي نجم عن تفجير امراه لقنبله
وكانت قوه الامن منعت الدخول لمنطقه
التفجير ودعت المواطنين لعدم مغادره
المنازل والمحل في المنطقه
كما فرضت هيئه الرقابه على الاعلام في
تركيا
والمحا الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان الى
ان الحادثه ارهابي وقال ان جهود اسقاط
الدوله التركيه من خلال الارهاب ستفشل
الدوله التركيه ستكون كفيله باظهار حقيقه
من نفذ هذا التفجير والذين سينالون عقابهم
والارهاب لن يصل الى هدفه والعناصر التي
حاولت النيل من الوحده التركيه لن تصل الى
مرادها لقد اطلعني ولي اسطنبول على اعداد
القتلى والجرحى وهذه الارقام يمكن ان
ترتفع
وايضا ردود الفعل المحليه عبر سياسيون
اتراك عن تعازيم لضحايا تفجير شارع
الاستقلال في اسطنبول زعيمه الحزب الصالح
المعارض ميرال اكشن نار ترحمت في تغريده
على تويتر ترحمت على ارواح الضحايا وضعت
بشفاء للجرحى
بدورها عبر رئيس حزب الشعب الجمهوريه
المعارض كمال كلش دار اوبلو عن تعازيه
للشعب التركي
للمواطنين الذين فقدوا ارواحهم وادي
الشفاء للجرحى كان اصدر حزب الشعوب
الديمقراطي بيانا عبر فيه عن بالغ الحزن
والاسى على الضحايا الذين سقطوا الجراء
الاستقلال
وينضم الينا من اسطنبول مراسل الجزيره عمر
الحاج عمر اخر التحديثات في المعلومات حول
هذا الانفجار
نائب الرئيس
شكل
ان عدد القتلى ما يزال
منهم في حاله الخطر وان هناك 38 من هؤلاء
تم اخلاقه سبيل تم خروجه من المشفى بعد ان
تلقوا كامل للعلاج ايضا في ملابسات الحادث
التفاصيل هذا الحادث بكير مصطفى وزير
العدل كان يتحدث عن همم بوجود حقيبه او
كيس كانت المسببه بهذا الانفجار وقال ان
هناك احتمالين الان تبحث فيهما قوات
الشرطه اما ان يكون هناك جهاز تفجير ذاتي
لهذه الحقيبه وهذا الكيس الذي وضع فكان
الانفجار او انه تم تفجيره عن بعد اكد مره
اخرى همم ان المسؤول ان كل الحديث الان عن
امراه هي التي وضعت هذه الحقيبه وانها
رصدت تجلس لمده 45 دقيقه بالمقرب في
بمقروبه من مكان التفجير ثم قامت بعد قبل
دقيقه واحده فقط من وقوع حادث الانفجار
وهذا يشير الى انها لم تفجر نفسها كما حدث
فيه هجوم سابق الخاصه ما وقع في هجوم على
ملعب الشيخ طارق في عام 2016 ايضا حتى
الان لم يعلن بكير عن اسم المتهمه او
الاسم هذه المجتبه بها اضافه الى ان
السلطات التركيه لم تتحدث او لم توجه
الاتهام الى اي من الاطراف التي عاده ما
كانت فقراء مثل هذه الهجمات ولكنها قالت
مره اخرى ان هذا هجوم ارهابي مدبر وان
تركيا سوف تختص من الجناح كما جاء على
لساني
رئيس الرئيس الرئيس اردوغان في تصريحات
السابقه وقال ان هذا لن يفوت من عضله تركي
من عضد تركيا في حربها المستمره على
مقارعه الارهاب لابد من الاشاره ايضا حسن
الى اهميه وحساسيه هذا الشارع الذي يعد
عصب الحياه
الاقتصاد هنا اضافه الى انه معلم سياحي
مهم في تركيا يرتده اكثر من اثنين مليون
شخص في كل يوم وانه [__] على كثير من
القنصليات والممثليات الدبلوماسيه همم
الغربيه في تركيا بما انه لم يتم توجيهه
الاتهام الى اي طرف بشكل مباشر وصريح لكن
عندما يصفه الرئيس اردوغان بانه تفجير
ارهابي هنا
همم الى من همم تتجه اصابع الاتهام او
الترجيحات في الاتهام عندما همم يوضع هذا
الوصف للانتاجار
حسن جهتان كانتا المسؤولتان عن كل
التفجيرات التي حدثت في تركيا خلال همم
السنوات في الاخلال العقد الماضي هما حزب
العمال الكردستاني المصنف ارهابيا من من
قبل القواته من قبل السلطات التركيه اضافه
الى تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه وكلاهما الجيش
التركي يخوضوا معهم سجالا سواء في شمال
العراق او في مناطق الشرقيه من تركيا او
حتى ضد المنظمات التي تعتبر انها تعتبرها
تركيا جزءا من حزب العمال الكردستاني هم
وحدات حمايه الشعب الموجوده في سوريا
وقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه اضافه الى تنظيم
الدوله الذي خاضت معه همم القوات التركيه
قتالا مباشره في سوريا وكانت هي المسؤوله
عن مقتل
وتسهيل الالقاء القبض او قتلي الكثير من
قادته واخرهم كان قائد التنظيم ابو بكر
البغدادي اسالنا قوات التحالف قالت ان
الاستخبارات التركيه المعلومات التي
قدمتها الاستخبارات التركيه كانت
مهمه في همم همم بايجاد مكانه وقتله في
شمال ادلب اذا هاتان هما الجهتان الرئيسيه
ولكن حتى الان نوجد هناك اي اتهام رسمي من
قبل السلطات التركيه لاي منهما منهما
شكرا لك عمر الحاج و اااه نريد ان ننوه
هنا عمر الى ان اا الامن التركي نشر صوره
لسيد المجتبه بانها تقف وراء هجوم اسطنبول
وهذه الصوره هي من من زوايا مختلفه وفي
هذا المجال نود ان نفهم منك همم سرعه نشر
هذه الصوره سرعه التعرف على هذه السيده
ونشر هذه الصوره بعد ساعات قليله من من
حدوث هذا الانفجار ما الذي يعني همم على
صعيد تسارع تحقيقات
يعني حسن هذا ربما من شانها ان يعجل
بالقاء القبض عليها والتعرف على شخصيتها
والتعرف على الجهه التي تقف وراءها اما
سرعه نشر هذه الصوره ايضا يعود حسن بلا شك
الى كثره الى وجود نظام امني كبير جدا هنا
في تركيا يتحدث عن نظام مراقبه امني هنا
في تركيا لا لا ننسى ان الهجوم الاخير
الذي وقع على سبيل المثال في في المنهل
الليلي في اسطنبول عامه في راس السنه في
عام 2017 تبكي السلطات من القائل القبض
على المنفذ بعد اقل من اربعه ايام وقالت
حينها انها راجعت اكثر من 100,000 ساعه من
كاميرات المراقبه كما ذكرت حسن هذا شارع
مهم جدا همم معلم سياحي اضافه الى وجود كل
هذه الممثلات التمثيلات الدبلوماسيه
والقنصليات فيه لابد ان تكون درجه
المراقبه فيه اعلى ولا بد ان كاميرات
المراقبه لاحظت وجود هذه السيده خاصه وان
حديثه وزير العدل يدل على ذلك انها مشتبه
بها خاص ده اذا ما قعدنا حديثه وقلنا انه
قال انها جلست باكثر من 45 دقيقه هذا
سيكون لافت للنظر لقوات الامن التي راجعت
كل هذه الاشرطه وعلى هذا الاساس نشرت هذه
الصوره ربما ايضا لنشر الصوره وان كانت لم
تظهر ملامح هذه السيده بالضبط ربما هذا من
شانه ان يحث المواطنين او من يعرف من
يمكنه التعرف على هذه همم الشخصيه او هذه
المراه المساهمه بادلاء المعلومات تسهل
القاء القبض عليها وبالتالي معرفه من وراء
هذا الهجوم ولكن مره اخرى يعني من تاريخ
له تركيا حسن هناك جهتان رئيسيتان دائما
ما يكوناني همم هما النسوان عن هذه
الهجمات وما تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه
بالمناسبه حسن
الهجوم بعجال باستخدام العناصر النسائيه
او همم حدث في تركيا وكان يقف وراء هذا
الهجوم حزب العمال الكردستاني في الهجوم
الذي اودى بحياته 38 شرطيا وقع في همم
في اسطنبول ننوه الى ان الجزيره حصلت على
صور للسيده المشتبه بانها تقف وراء هذا
الهجوم هجوم اسطنبول والذي وقع في شارع
الاستقلال
بماذا يتميز هذا الشارع شارع الاستقلال
يعني بالتحليل لماذا استهدافه من قبل من
قام بهذا التفجير
حسن كما ذكرت هو عصب السياحه هنا في
اسطنبول اكبر شارع للمشاي يرتاده اكثر من
اثنين مليون شخص يوميا هذا وفقا للاحصاءات
الرسميه
بالمعالم الثقافيه والمعالم التاريخيه همم
عمر همم عمر عذرا فقط
لانه
هذه الصور همم السيده
بان تقف وراء هذا الهجوم
كنا نشاهد هذه الصوره هي امراه
محجبه كما هو واضح اذا كنت تحدث عمر عن
اهميه هذا الشارع شارع الاستقلال ورمزيته
في قلب اسطنبول
نعم حسن كنت اقول انه اكبر شارع للمشاير
تادله اكثر من اثنين مليون شخص يوميا وفقا
للاحصاءات الرسميه وفيه الكثير من المعالم
التاريخيه الحقيقه هو قبله السياح ذلك انه
شارع المشرف او القريب من ساحه الاستقلال
ساحه تقسيم هنا رمز مدينه اسطنبول
وقبله السياح عين الصحه القول اضافه الى
كونه يتوسط المدينه يصلها الى الكثير من
المعالم التاريخيه برج غلطه اضافه الى
شارعي الى حيث كلها احياء سياحيه هنا في
اسطنبول يعني الاختيار اختيار هذا المكان
بالطبع لم يكون عبثا وبالمناسبه هذه ليست
المره الاولى التي يشهد فيها هذا الشارع
هذا النوع من الهجمات قبل همم عده اعوام
ايضا كان هناك محاوله للاعتداء او اليهود
على بعض السياح الذي تبين فيما بعد انهم
يحملون جواز السفر
الاسرائيلي اي يعني هذا ما يعني انها
اختيار هذا الهدف بالتحديد وايضا لابد من
الحديث عن التوقيت حسنا البلاد مقبله على
استحقاق
انتخابيا بعد عده اشهر ربما كان هذا
المناسب للهجوم يريد ان يحرج حزب العداله
والتنميه الحاكم بتحقيق مثل هذا الاختراق
الامني واحداث مثل هذا التفجير في وقت
تقول تركيا انها همم تضمن فيه ان مواطنها
وانها تمنع اختراق اني ايضا فيما يخص
التوقيت ايضا همم حزب همم تركيا ما تزال
تخوض حربا ضد عناصر حزب العمال
كردستانيات سميت بعمليات المخلب تقوم بها
تركيا في شمال العراق وايضا في مناطق في
سوريا اليوم كان هناك اعلان عن استهداف
قياده لحزب العمال الكردستاني في سوريا
كذلك الامر بالنسبه لتنظيم الدوله الذي
كما ذكرنا كان ل تركيا الدور الكبير في
القاء القبض على كثير من قادته وتصفيه
بعضهم بالتعاون مع قوات التحالف ضد تنظيم
الدوله الاسلاميه في سوريا والعراق هذا
هذا يعني ان يعني ان تركيا الان في مرحله
تخوض فيها حرب مع منظمات معروفه باقدامها
على مثل هذه العمليات وان كانت كما ذكرنا
لم تنفذ لم تلقي باللوم او بالاتهام على
اي همم منها
بشكلنا نشاهده ومن اكثر من زاويه لهذه
المراه التي يشربها في انها همم هي من تقف
وراء هجوم اسطنبول طبعا كانت مره في في
هذا الشارع مثلها مثل المئات الذين كانوا
مارين في هذا الشارع خصوصا في هذا التوقيت
الذي تتحدث فيه اليوم همم يوم احد وفي
ساعات اصدر ايضا فربما لم تثر
انتباهه احد باعتبارها انها امراه عاديه
في اا تمر على الطريق في الشارع المستهدف
همم لذلك ربما من هنا اود ان اسال همم عمر
يعني
هل يحرج هذا الامر
السلطات باعتباره اختراقا امنيا وخصوصا ان
هذا الشارع يرتده همم يعني همم المئات او
ربما الالاف يوميا خصوصا في اوقات الذروه
حسن لابد من الاشاره الى ان هذه ليست
المره الاولى التي تتعرض فيها تركيا في ظل
حك حكم حزب العداله والتنميه
للبلاد لمثل هذه الهجمات بل ان البعض منها
كان هجمات لن نستطيع وصفه بالدميه اذا ما
اشرنا الى عدد القتلى على سبيل المثال ما
حدث في ميدان في العاصمه في عام
2014 في 2013 حين وقع اكثر من 200 واثنى
عشر قتيلا في ذلك الهجوم تمناه ايضا حزب
العمال الكردستاني الحقيقه هنا اذا كنا
نتحدث عن سباق الانتخابات المحموم وايضا
تحميد اللائمه او ربما تسجيل نقطه ضد حزب
العداله والتنميه
وحتى المؤيده لسياسات حزب العداله
والتنميه تتوحد في موقفها باداره مثل هذه
الهجمات والدعوه والتوحد ورص الصفوف وايضا
الوقوف صفا واحدا ضد كل من يهاجم تركي
الحقيقه مثل هذه الهجمات تجمع الاحزاب
السياسيه عالاقل مما نشهد هنا اكثر من
موضوع التفرقه وموضوع القاء اللوم على طرف
دون اخر نعم في في هذه النقطه تحديدا عمر
تبعنا بعض ردود الفعل المحليه وكانت في
الاطار الذي همم تتحدث عنه ايدانا
واستنكار داخلي ل همم هذا التفجير همم على
ابواب الانتخابات كيف يمكن ان نفهم اللغه
الواحده اذا صاحب تعبير داخليا همم
بمواجهه واستنكار هذا الانفجار
كما ذكرت حسن في ما يخص هذه القضايا سواء
حين يقع هجوم يصنف بالارهاب على مدنيه
وحتى هجمات تستهدف قوات الشرطه او الجيش
داخل الاراضي التركيه او خارجها على او
خارجها عاده ما يكون موقف الاحزاب
السياسيه بمختلفه توجهاتها هو موقف
مساند
لعمل الحكومه بشكل عام دون تسميه الاحزاب
ونرى ان هناك صوتا واحدا ينادي دائما
القصاص من المنفذين وايضا المواساه وطالب
الرحمه
للقتلى ولي الضحايا ودعوه للتوحد وتلافي
خلافات في سبيل
المحافظه على امن واستقراري البلاد هذا
بشكل عام سواء في الهجمات التي كانت تتعرض
لها القوات التركيه في سوريا او في مناطق
او حتى في الهجمات التي تحدثنا عنها في
وقت سابق سواء في انقره وفي اسطنبول يعني
نادرا نجد اي نوع من انواع القاء اللون او
همم اتهام بالتقسيط من جانب على باتجاه
اخر حول مسؤوليتي عن مثل هذه الاعمال لان
تركيا دائما معارضه وحكومه تتحدث دائما ان
تركيا بلد مستهدف تركيا فيها هناك الكثير
من الاعداء الذين يحاولون النيله منها
ايضا احداث اختراقات امنيه فيها وبالتالي
الفته من عزيمتها من قوه تركيا خاصه بعد
ما تقول حكم انه تنامي لدور اقليمي وعالمي
لتركيا في الفتره الاخيره اذا يعني بالنظر
الى السماء والى ما حصل من ردود افعال
يمكن هنا همم يعني ابعاد اذا صحت تعبير
عامل الانتخابات او همم استثمار هذا
التفجير في الانتخابات نحو البحث عن عوامل
اخرى عوامل الضغط تحدث عنها الرئيس
اردوغان اليوم عوامل الضغط لها علاقه
بالحرائق التركي الدولي
صحيح صحيح حسن يعني
مره اخرى في مراجعه الاحداث السابقه اي من
الفرقاء السياسيين لم يستخدمه مثل هذه
الاحداث كورق ضد الحكومه ضد حزب العداله
والتنميه وحلفائه الذي يقود البلاد منذ
اكثر من عقدين ولكن تستخدم ملفات اخرى كم
ملفات الازمه الاقتصاديه وايضا تدني السعر
صرف الليره الليره التركيه مقابل العملات
الاخرى اضافه الى الاتهامات باستبداد
بالسلطه وايضا قمع بعض الحريات وتغيير شكل
الدوله بعد التحول من النظام البرلمان
البرلماني الى النظام الرئاسي لكن فيما
يخص هذه الاتهامات بالتقصير الامني او ما
يشبهها من اتهامات فالكل يعرف حكومه
ومعارضه ان البلاد مستهدفه وان هناك
الكثير من العداء يعني صراع حزب العداله
الصراع الدوله التركيه كما يقول مسؤول
الاتراك مع حزب العمال الكردستاني المصنف
ارهابيا من قبل تركيا عمره اكثر من 40 عام
يعني قبل حتى عق من تسلسل حزب العداله
والتنميه اضافه الى همم اعتبار المعارضه
وايضا الحكومه لتنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه
عدوا لتركيا عدوا للامم التركيه وبالتالي
فان ايا من هذه الاطراف السياسيه لا يستغل
مثل هذه
المعارك او هذه الهجمات لي وجهها اتهاما
او نقدا او بالتقصير
وعدم اتخاذ كافه الاجراءات المطلوبه من
قبل المعارضه ضد الحكومه ضد اجهزتها
الامنيه همم
نبقى ايضا في اطارنا نشاهده همم
الصور صوره السيده همم التي
وراء هذا الهجوم وقد حصلت الجزيره همم على
هذه الصوره ومن زوايا مختلفه
يعني التعرف
يعني اذا لا ادري ان كنت تشاهدها بشكل
دقيق عمر ولكن
هل يفترض انه سيكون من السهل التعرف على
هذه السيده في ضوء الاجراءات الامنيه
المتخذه حاليا بعد التفجير مباشره والتي
من المفترض ان تكون الاجراءات اكثر تشددا
واكثر استقصاءا عنها
نعم بدايه الحسن نريد ان يشير الى ان هذه
الصور التي حصلت عليها الجزيره كانت قد
صادفت لحظات تصوير احد من اصحاب المحال
واصحاب العمال التجاريه المشرف على الساحه
وحتى حتى صاحب الصور لم لم يدرك ان هذه هي
الشخصيه الا بعد انتشار السور لها في تلك
في وسائل الاعلام التركيه الحقيقه هذا
طبعا من شانه ان يسهل عمل السلطات التركيه
وان كانت كما ذكرنا تتحدث بحذر عن كل
التفاصيل التي تفضي الى الى القاء القبض
عليها ربما ان كان هناك تفاصيل تساعدها في
الخروج من اسطنبول انا اريد فقط ان اذكر
حادثه مهمه حسن انا غطينا الهجوم الذي حدث
على الموقع على المنهى الليلي في اسطنبول
كنا هناك كانت السلطات تروج لروايه مختلفه
تماما على ما اتبين لاحقا انه هو الروايه
الحقيقيه ضفت عن تمكني هذا
المنفذ من الهرب من التخفي بازين ماء وانه
ما يزال موجودا ضمن هذا الحين يتبين بعد
ذلك ان السلطات الرسميه كانت تنشر مثل هذه
الروايه حتى ااه حتى تضلل ربما او تشتت من
همم من خطط هذا المنفس ثم بعد ذلك تمكن من
القبض عليه الان السلطات التركيه ربما
تريد ان تضيق الخناق اكثر على هذه المنفذه
بعد ان انتشرت لها هذه الصور حتى حدثت
الجهه التي غادرت منها الميدان مكان هذا
التفجير الى مكان اخر وبالتالي فعلا هذا
يساعد اكثر المدن ربما من شهدها بالتعرف
عليها اكثر وتقصير همم ربما فتره زمنيه
للقاء همم القبض عليها مره اخرى انظمه
المراقبه هنا في تركيا وايضا السلطات
الامنيه اثبت الجداره خلال الاحداث
الماضيه في همم القبض على مثل هؤلاء واي
الوصول الى نتائج سريعه في وقت القياسي
لهذه الحوادث يعني نتحدث عن الانفجار الذي
وقع قبل نحوي اربع بالراحه ست ساعات ربما
او سبع ساعات من الان والان السلطات تتحدث
عن
التعرف شبه التعرف على هويه هذه
السيده وانها تنشر صورا لها كيف انها جلست
اكثر من 45 دقيقه في مقعد قريب من مكان
الانفجار ثم بعد ذلك غادرت قبل دقيقه
واحده فقط من الانفجار وهذا ايضا اشاره
الى ان ربما السلطات تفرج قليلا عن بعض
المعلومات لانها لم بدايه لم تتحدث كانت
هذه السيده قد فجرت نفسها كما في حوادث
سابقه انها همم تركت هذه الحقيبه لان نعرف
يعرف الجميع انها غادرت المكان وهن هناك
صور تدل على شخصيتها ربما ستتكشف هويتها
خلال السعاده
الامور ولكن يعني
بطبيعه الامور عندما همم ترصد بالصور هذه
السيده وقد جلست مده 40 او 45 دقيقه قبل
ان همم تمشي من المفترض عمليا يعني
بالمنطق ان يكون ما تركته ايضا قد رصدته
الكاميرات ان كانت ان كان كيسا او حقيبه
او فجرت نفسها او شيء من هذا القبيل يعني
همم ما رايه
هذا دلل عليه حديث همم حديث سابق لوزير
العدل بكير مزدوه وقال فيه ان السلطات
الان تعمل على تحليلي هذه الماده هي الان
سلطات او فرق التحقيق التركيه تعمل على
البحث في بقايا هذه الحقيبه وفي بقايا هذه
المواد المتفجره لعلهم فعلا وصلوا الى ذلك
والى الارض وما لم يشر اليه بصراحه وزير
العدل وعن طريق هذه التحقيقات قد تتمكن
ايضا السلطات من معرفه الجهه المسؤوله اذا
ان لكل همم جهه او لكل طرف المشتبه به
طريقه خاصه وموده خاصه يستخدمها في مثل
هذه همم العمليات مره اخرى حسن نحن نتحدث
عن الاف رجال الشرطه اتحدث عن همم فرق
مدربه عملت مع هذه الحوادث الطيره عقد من
الزمن اضافه الى الخبرات السابقه قبل ان ت
همم تتوسع هجمات هذه التنظيمات ايا كانت
سواء الى المدن همم او الى في ال- اا
البلاد كذلك الامر التطويق هذه المنطقه
بكل هذه الحوادث اضافه الى نشر همم الالاف
من رجال الشرطه ورجال الشرطه المدنيه
والمباحث هذا كله سيسهل بشكل او باخر ومره
اخرى لكن نحن نريد السابق الاحداث ولكن
نحن نتحدث عن اجراءات تطبق في كل مره
تتعرض فيها البلاد لمثل هذه همم الهجمات
لا نست ايضا ان تركيا كما ذكرنا تمتع بهذا
النظام العالي الدقه من كاميرات المراقبه
والعلم من زار المدينه يدرك تماما عما
نتحدث هذا اضافه الى همم عمليات التفتيش
التي تكون صارمه والتسجيل همم لاشخاص
الذين يرتدون المحطات سواء المحطات المترو
او حتى محطات الحافلات ابقى معنا عمر
الحاج همم سنبقى في نفس الملف معنا من
اسطنبول السفير فكره اوزير الدبلوماسيه
السابق في الخارجيه التركيه مرحبا بك سيد
همم فكره همم
برايك برايك من الذي يريد اسقاط الدوله
التركيه من خلال الارهاب و سيفشل كما قال
الرئيس اردوغان
[تصفيق]
وخلق المشاكل همم اجتماعيه داخل طبعا كمال
تريده كما تعلمون ان همم
منظمات ارهابيه همم وراءهم همم فيكانات
اخرى هذا معروف
وتتكا معروف داعش معروف
وهممته همم دوله موازيه ايضا همم دوله
موازيه كما تعلمون همم
15 سم مباشره
طبعا هذا حاليا اييه 8 من النوار وهم
يحققون مع ااا جهات الامن همم لم يعلنوا
فاعله فاعله همم حتى يتبين همم
يتبين همم الشخص
همم هي تابعه همم طبعا همم
تركيا همم
بيستهدف امن والامان همم مستهدف همم
اقتصاد التركيه والسياحه همم قاموا هذا في
بشتارامو بهذا ال همم العمليه في ميدان
السلطان احمد همم تركيا وجهات الامن همم
دائما ضد همم مثل هذه المحاولات قبل
همم
متسربين من حدود سوريا داخل تركيا قبضوا
عليهم في قرب اسطنبول همم سيد همم
ما هو الهدف عفوا ما هو الهدف من هذه
التفجيرات الان وفي هذا التوقيت الذي
يعتبر حساس في تركيا
يمكن يستهدف همم الامن الداخلي خلال هذه
المده همم لمنع
نزاهه منع نزاهه قيام بالانتخابات
طبعا يعني الان لا يمكننا ان نقول ولا
نتهم اي جهه حتى يتبين شخصيه همم هذه
منافذه
هل تتوقع ان ان ايه
يتاخر
الاعلان عن
المنفذ او المنفذه او الجهه التي تقف وراء
تنفيذ هذا التفجير
طبعا هذا
يعني في بعض الاحيان اهم شيء من المنفذ
ما وراءه يعني كما تعلمون
وهمم يعني وهم يقومون
يعني يستخدمها التقيه يمكن
منظمه تانيه لكن ايه يقدم نفسه شيئا ثاني
يعني اعتقد حتى يتبين ما وراءه
ايه هذا يعني الجهه والشخص يمكن يتاخر
يعني حتى يتم التحقيق بالموضوع من وجهه
نظرك
يعني
الى اي طرف تميل الترجيحات اكثر في
امكانيه ان يكون قد قام بهذا الهجوم وهو
الاكثر استفاده منه
الله طبعا يعني
جهاد امنيه تركيه همم قام همم عمليات مهمه
جدا مثلا قبل يومين همم قد همم
قد
قاموا همم اباده همم اهم اشخاص في داخل
سوريا في همم
وفي اخر همم ايام همم قد قام بعمليات ضد
ههه
اذا همم ضد داعش نفس الشيء يعني من يمكن
من خلالهما
همم يعني اما ان يكون من تنظيم الدوله او
الجهه المخططه من تنظيم الدوله او البيبك
او او حزب العمال الكردستاني
[موسيقى]
قاموا بعمليات مهمه جدا يعني يمكن
يعني في طرفين يمكن قاموا بانتقاما من هذه
العمليات
هل هل تتوقع ان يكون لدور تركيا الدولي
ولل الدور الدوري الذي تلعب تركيا على
صعيد الوساطه في ازمه في في الحرب الروسيه
على اوكرانيا وايضا فيما يتعلق بالوسطات
الدوليه والحراك الدولي عموما الذي يقوم
به اردوغان الرئيس التركي هل تتوقع ان
يكون له همم ان يكون سببا همم لهذه
التفجيرات
والله هذا ممكن كما اشاره رئيس طيب
اردوغان يعني عندما تلقى هذا الخبر قال
يرى انه اييي
انه عمل ارهابي طبعا الوقت
تنفيذ هذه تفتيرات الوقت من هذه الجهه
اييه يعني
مهمه جدا
التوقيت التوقيت في التوقيت مهم جدا ماذا
اجتماع الاتحاد
دول المنظمه اتحاد الدول الاتراك
واثناء هذه الوساطه بين دولتين مجاريتين
من ناحيه التوقيع
يمكن منعه دوره تركيا دوليه
الان على المستوى الدولي اي ضغوط تتعرض
همم لها تركيا في هذا التوقيت وانت تركز
كثيرا على التوقيت داخليا اشرت الى
اقتراب موعد الانتخابات لكن التوقيت
في المسار الخارجي ربما يكون اكثر اهميه
في الحقيقه ااا يعني الداخليا اييي تركيا
كل الاطراف المعارضه
والحكومه
وهمم
يستعيدون للانتخابات
التركيه طبعا يحتاج الامن والامان لهذا
اذا للي تمكن من دور الوساطه بين همم بين
همم بين الاطراف يجب ان يكون يعني همم
بدون مشاكل في الداخل اذا كان في داخل همم
مشاكل داخل داخليه لا يمكن ان تهتم بامور
الدوليه
من على المستوى الخارجي من من الدول او من
الاطراف الدوليه التي
من مصلحتها اشغال تركيا بوضع امني داخلي
غير مستقر من
طبعا لا يمكن ان يسمي اي دوله
لكن يعني في من من طبيعه علاقات الدوليه
يقولون الدبلوماسيه اذا اذا كنت غضبان يجب
ان تخفي غضبك اذا فرحنا يجب
تخفي همم فرحتك
من ناحيه كده طبعا لا يمكن ان نسمي الان
لكن بعد فتره ااا في ال ال اشارات او في
بعض
الفعاليات دوليه يمكننا ان يعني ان يمكننا
ان نسميه حاليا طبعا لا يمكن همم قبل ان
يعلن هويه هذا الشخص لا يمكن ان يسمي اي
اقرا
طبعا انا سالته كان ليس بمنطق توجيه
الاتهام بقدر
منطق التحليل من من الدول التي تستفيد من
ذلك بغض النظر ان كانت اصابع اتهام توجه
او لا توجه اليها ليس هنا المقصود المقصود
بمن يستطيع ان يستثمر او يستفيد همم من
هذا التفجير خارجيا
طبعا
هناك همم هناك
همم
عده دول
يعني همم لهم مشاكل بتركيا
طبعا همم يعني بدون
اي همم دليل لا يمكن ان ان نسميهم او نتهم
بهم
شكرا جزيلا لك فكره ازاله الدبلوماسيه
السابق في الخارجيه التركيه كنت معنا من
اسطنبول
نعود من جديد الى عمر
الحاج من جديد اليك عمر وزير الصحه التركي
يقول ان 42 جريحا سقطوا في انفجار اسطنبول
لا يزالون يتلقون العلاج بينهم خمسه في
العنايه المركزه واثنان بحاله خطيره هل
لديك ايه معلومات اضافيه على هذا الصعيدي
نعم حسن هذا فيه اشاره الى ارتفاع عدد
الحالات الخطره التي اتحدثت عنها السلطات
التركيه اخر تحديث كان لوزير الصحه وايضا
لفؤاد اقطاي نائب الرئيس التركي قال ان 81
جريحا بينهم اثنان في حاله خطره الان
نتحدث عن
خمس حالات خطيره بالرغم من ان السلطات
التركيه قالت ان 39 من هؤلاء الجرحى تم
خروجه من المستشفى بعد ان تلقوا
كافه الاجراءات الطبيه والعلاج همم الذين
همم في المستشفيات ايضا همم نريد ان نشير
فقط الى ان هذا العدد حسن يشير الى قوه
هذا الانفجار تحدث عن 81 شخصا وتحدث عن
سته قتله اضافه الى ان الصور والفيديوهات
التي التقطت اثناء هذا التفجير التي اظهرت
بصوت الانفجار
تحدث عن عمليه ربما تكون مركزه وكان هدف
منها احداث اكبر اخ همم قدر ممكن من
الاصابات خاصه منما تحدثنا عن شارع
المقتضن ومكان مقتضن مثل شارع الاستقلال
هنا وسط مدينه اسطنبول يعني حديث سلطات من
منذ البدايه كانت حدث ان عدد القتلى مرجح
للارتفاع وهذا ايضا مره اخرى طريقه تتبعها
القوات التتبعها السلطات التركيه همم
للتمهيد لسقوط مثل هؤلاء الضحايا على سبيل
المثال منذ البدايه في هجوم اسطنبول
الاخيره الذي حدث كما ذكرنا همم تم الح-
ال- ال- الافصاح عن 28 عن 30 قتيلا ثم ثم
انتهى ثلاث الروايه الرسميه الى اكثر من
45 او 48 شخصا قضوا من جنسيات مختلفه ايضا
لابد من الاشاره الى ان حتى الان لا نعلم
جنسيات القتلى حسن نحن نتحدث عن شارع ان
يرتاده الناس من مختلفه الدول والمختلف
الجنسيات السلطات حتى الان لم تفصح كانوا
هؤلاء كلهم من الاتراك امن هناك جنسيات
اخرى ضمن القتله شكرا لك عمر الحاج مراسل
الجزيره حدثتنا من اسطنبول
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
مشاهدينا عمليه تفجير التي شهدتها اسطنبول
قبل ساعات اعاده الى الاضواء مجددا ميدانت
تقسيم التاريخيه يقع الميدان شهير في
منطقه بولو في قلب اسطنبول الحديثه وهو
نقطه الجذب السياحي الرئيسيه وتعود تسميته
الى انه كان مركزا لتقسيم امدادات المياه
وتوزيعها في العهد العثماني يقتظ ميدان
تقسيم بالمطاعم والمتاجر والفنادق
وويكالات الاسفار من نجعلهم مقصدا ترفيهيا
للسياحي والاتراك وهو يضم نصب الجمهوريه
التذكاريه والمحطه الرئيسيه لشبكه مترو
انفاق اسطنبول
مثاليه للمظاهرات والاحداث الاجتماعيه
والوطنيه وقد كان على مدى اكثر من نصف قرن
ساحه للاحتجاجات والفعاليات السياسيه
المنوئه للسلطه
وتتفرع من الميدان شوارع كثيره اشهروها
شارع الاستقلال الذي وقع فيه تفجير اليوم
ويبلغ طوله تقريبا ثلاثه كيلو مترات وهو
يحتوي الكثير من المباني الاثريه والملاهي
والعديد من السفارات والقنصليه
التفجير الجديد انها نحو خمسه اعوام من
الهدوء في اسطنبول اذ كانت المدينه قبل
ذلك هدفا لهجمات دمويه نفذها تنظيم الدوله
وجماعات كرديه
ففي بدايه عام 2016 هزا في جارا ميدان
سلطان احمد وسط اسطنبول مختلفه 10 قتله
وخمسه عشر جريحا معظمهم من السياح
الالماني بعد نحو شهرين من ذلك فجرا تحرير
من تنظيم الدوله نفسه في شارع الاستقلال
قرب ميدان تقسيم حيث سقط عشرات بين قتيل
وجريح وفي يونيو من حزيران من العام نفسه
استاذ هجوم حافله للشرطه قرب محطه
للحافلات من منطقه مزدحمه وسط اسطنبول
وحملت الحكومه جماعه كرديه المسؤوليه عن
الهجوم
بعد اسبوعين من ذلك قتل اكثر من 30 شخصا
في هجوم النفذه ثلاثه انتحاري بمطار تترك
الدولي في اسطنبول ورجحت انقره وقوف تنظيم
الدوله ورائه
ومع فجر اول يوم من عام 2017 استهدفا من
تنظيم الدوله ملهم ليليا في اسطنبول خلال
الاحتفالات براس السنه الجديده فقتلوا نحو
40 شخصا واصابه حول 70 اخرين
ينضم الينا من انقره نجده
اوزجيلاك المحلل السياسي والخبير العسكري
مرحبا بك سيد نجدد
ما ابرز مال فتك في هذا الهجوم على صعيد
التخطيط والتنفيذ
[موسيقى]
العمليه هي الطريق او المنهجيه حيث اننا
نعرفوا ان كان هناك
عبوه ناسفه وضعت في هذه الحقيبه
والشبهه هي بشان سيده
صوت الضيف انقطع من المصدر
[موسيقى]
السعودي بها
وايضا كان هناك
هجمات في السابق
تعتمدوا على تقنيه
الانتحاريين ولكننا نتحدث الان عن تفجير
عن بعد
وقامت
بتنفيذه امراه
سوف ننتظر التحقيقات لتاكيد من يقف خلف
هذا الهجوم
هل تجد فيه اوجه شبه مع التفجيرات السابقه
التي
شهدتها اسطنبول
يعني اسطنبول
في اسطنبول
تنظيم داعش ايضا في العام 2016 المدينه
اذا نتحدث فيها عن تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه
بنسبه الى حزب العمال الكردستاني في العام
تم التنفيذ هجوم مستهدفه مباراه ليست
بعيده عن ميدان التقسيم
عن
التقنيه
المستخدمه بالاضافه الى المتفجرات
السابقه ولكن يتعين علينا ان ننتظر
التحقيقات لكي نعرف
الجهه التي تقف بشكل مؤكد خلف هذا الهجوم
اذا هناك مؤشرات
باتجاه حزب العمال الكردستاني بالاضافه
الى التقنيه يمكننا ان نتحدث عن التوقيت
الخاص بهذا الهجوم
اه اود ان اذكر الجميع انه منذ ايام كان
هناك لقاء
بالنسبه الى
اوزباكست في اوزباكستان
وفي القمه المعقوده
اذا
تم قبول عضويه
جمهوريه قبرص الشماليه في هذه
القمه وبالتالي
بين سامسونج
في اطار
الاحداث التي جرت في
المنطقه
وهناك جهات فاعل ايضا يمكن ان تاخذ بعين
الاعتبار على مستوى الدول
اذا
الشبهه هي
تحوم حول حزب العمال الكردستاني بالاضافه
الى جهات اخرى
حبيبي وايضا لدينا اتفاق تصدير الحبوب
والذي من المفترض ان يتم
تمديده او تجديده في هذا الاسبوع وبالتالي
هذا الامر يصلي الضوء على توقيت هذا
الهجوم
السيد نجدت عذرا يعني كانني افهم منك ان
امم يعني كانك تريد ان تقول ان الاهداف
اهداف هذا التفجير هي اهداف دوليه وخارجيه
اكثر منه اهداف داخليه مرتبطه بتوقيت
الانتخابات وغير ذلك المساله هي اكبر
بكثير من همم يعني الضغط الداخلي يمارسه
حزب العمال الكردستاني الى الليل هذا اذا
ثبت انه هو من يقف وراء التبجيل
يستمشن
هذا الهجوم بالاضافه الى عوامل المحليه
اخرى يجب ان تاخذ بعين الاعتبار
الارهابيون يحاولون يحاولون ان يستغلوا
البيئه
ونحن نعرف ان هناك
موسم انتخابيه في البلاد
دميه
في السابق من قبل بعض الاصوات في الداخل
كان
القاء اللوم على القوات الامنيه
في شانها للعمليات في شمالي العراق
والتي استهدفت حزب العمال الكردستاني وكان
هناك اتهامات بان القوات الامنيه التركيه
استخدمت الاسلحه الكيميائيه وهذه
الاتهامات الهدف منها الضغط على السلطات
التركيه على الحكومه وعلى وزاره الداخليه
التركيه على وجه الخصوص وبالتالي يمكن ان
نتحدث هنا عن جهه خارجيه وايضا عن جهه
داخليه
[موسيقى]
من انقره
يذكر ان موقع الانفجار كان في شارع
الاستقلال بمنطقه بي اوغلو بالجزء
الاوروبي من المدينه الشارع الاستقلال هو
اكثر شوارع اسطنبول المخصصه للمشاه
اكتضاضا
ختام الحصاد شكرا لمتابعتكم مشاهدينا والى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]